and uh he is my favorite language
imperialist okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh sure
okay great
at the end of the beginning yeah
all right hi everybody let me start my
clock here so I have something
um today I'm going to give my
perspective on where NLP is going in the
age of large language models like is
this an ending or some kind of new
beginning
I'm going to start the story way way
back and vastly oversimplify
um I'm going to oversimplify everything
it starts about 70 years ago like just a
few years after the transistor was
invested and people started thinking
about having machines do things that
people require and require intelligence
and so maybe we could start this in like
1950 with uh trying's imitation game or
maybe in 1955 when McCarthy coined this
term artificial intelligence that we've
all been sort of living with ever since
For Better or Worse and so there's this
box called artificial intelligence and
it's really broad it contains all kinds
of things but what's really in this box
um this box has been kind of hard to pin
down more because of the eye than
because of the a it's been hard to pin
down what's intelligence so you know
like maybe finding square roots
shouldn't be in this box not because
it's not hard for humans but you know
it's really easy for computers so in
this box is really things that are easy
for humans but hard for machines so a
classic example would be something like
chess right this is something that seems
to require a lot of intelligence in
humans and at least for a while it
seemed really hard for machines but AI
can be this incredibly self-eating
concept right because if you take
something like chess and it's clearly a
great example of artificial intelligence
because we just can't solve it or go but
then once systems are good enough that
they're exceeding human capacity we have
this way of looking at and saying you
know what actually maybe chess is like
very configurational it's like this
logic puzzle maybe it's the kind of
thing that computers should be good at
maybe humans surprising humans can do as
well as they can so maybe it's not
really such a core example of AI anymore
so I just want us all to be on the
lookout for cases where once we solve
something suddenly we decide that's not
AI That's not intelligence that's just
uh as aliosha would say a bunch of
correlations
um
so anyway so what's in this box it's
very broad it can taste things like
natural language or Vision Robotics and
so on and
um
and it seems like
the one thing we can agree about in this
box is it's very broad so sanjiv talked
about there being lots of skills and any
task involving tuples of skill so this
is like combinatory broad as a box so
anyway really broad back to the 50s
people have this broad box and they
wanted a broad solution for it and a
cartoon of the time is that people
thought well at least some people maybe
thought that everything could run on
some kind of uniform substrate like
maybe that would be first order logic
and executed on a system like say a
prologue uh kind of environment
and all right so all kinds of things did
not fit into this Frame things that we
would consider artificial intelligence
now work in image processing work in
speech recognition and so on but for at
least a large chunk of things that
people were interested in
um there was this dream of doing it in a
uniform way
um
like for example uh in prologue with
fresh starter logic and that could be
done maybe by one community
with one set of techniques
um and maybe you could send all your
papers to one place like whatever you
did if it was AI it could go to AAA or
hki or something like that so there was
this hope of a uniform approach now
there was a problem which is that
nothing whatsoever worked but it did so
uniformly right
all right so um this is where the story
starts to get interesting for me because
I am an NLP person so I do NLP and this
is where NLP shows up into the movie
um and Broad techniques turned out not
to work and if you approached every
problem with just some simple logical
deduction rules then you either didn't
get deep enough into the real problems
to solve them or maybe all of your rules
started to conflict with each other in
some way that wasn't very robust in any
case what happened in practice is we got
stuck in blocks worlds and in order to
make progress Beyond this you needed to
specialize and what you happened is
people specialized into verticals like
my favorite vertical natural language
processing natural language processing
started to look very different from the
rest of AI right it wasn't just write
some stuff down in first order logic we
started to think about things like
context-free grammars we had algorithms
that were specialized for example uh
Dynamic programs like CKY for doing
inference over those when we start to
get to get to data sets we needed data
sets for those particular representation
patients machine learning algorithms for
those kinds of combinatorial structures
and this all got very specialized in a
way that was different from other areas
for example Vision had their own while
NLP was thinking about
trees and co-reference resolution people
envisioned were thinking about Edge
detection or object detection and we're
using techniques that looked you know
more like things resting on linear
algebra and so on and you know this sort
of replicated across all of AI each
vertical worked on its problems its
representations its algorithms and in
order in order to actually make progress
here you actually ended up going quite
deep so maybe I should actually draw it
like this because each sub-area did end
up going very deep into their own
domains
and their own representations
so let's zoom in on NLP okay so what
really made these verticals what made
them different from all the rest why
were we not trying to have some uniform
solution for AI anymore and if we zoom
in on NLP we can think about it's really
because we needed better representations
to get anything to work and if you think
about it now the NLP representations are
probably going to look very different
from the ones in robotics or computer
vision
so um
this raised a problem what are the
representations exactly and it turned
out there was another field that was
thinking exactly this question about
language and this was Linguistics and
the closest piece of that was
computational Linguistics and so NLP
became very closely aligned with
computational Linguistics because step
one to making all of the NLP
applications we care about work was
essentially solve computational
Linguistics so for step one of doing NLP
we first had to do CL
and that meant that these two Fields
were brought into very close alignment
of course people had different goals and
I'm vastly oversimplifying but there was
a lot of overlap
um and this same phenomenon of AI being
too broad and different representations
Vision versus language this replicated
within each of the domains so for
example in natural language processing
we have subfields these are verticals
within vertical so parsing people had
context-free grammars and algorithms
like CKY data like the pantry bank and
so on co-reference resolution is about
finding partitions and linkages under
various kinds of linguistic or empirical
constraints and so on and in general the
story was that NLP was super hard and we
had to get the representations right and
so again we were very aligned with
computational Linguistics this is going
to be important for later step one of
NLP is do computational Linguistics all
right the road LED through computational
Linguistics because that's where the
representations were and by the way this
was very real so this is a caricature
but it's not that much of a caricature
so I dug up the program from ACL 2013
and you can see that the tracks in the
conferences are basically isomorphic to
this decomposition I've given you
um okay I made the colors match that was
on me but the fact that there's the
syntax track where they're doing all the
syntax things and there's a semantics
track where they're doing the semantics
things and so on and each one is using
different techniques different subsets
of researchers and so on it's a
fragmented world
all right
[Music]
so
there's a piece I left out of that says
really important and that is that people
were definitely interested in doing
things that were Broad and things that
were cross-cutting some of that was
approaches to data some of that was
approaches to to statistical learning
and in fact on that one of the tracks
was a machine learning track one of the
things that people really really wanted
was the ability to have some kind of
portable general knowledge so this has
been a long-standing goal in NLP since
like forever so as soon as people had
computational methods one of the first
things people were doing was clustering
words
um decades and decades ago and one of
the things that people thought you might
be able to do with word clusters even
back before word to vac right far before
like in the 80s people had basically
reasonable word clusters Brown clusters
in the 90s and one of the things we
thought as well independent of all this
other stuff if we're going to be parsing
these sentences and finding their
syntactic structure it might be nice to
know that if I see a word like silver
and I've never seen it before but I do I
have seen the word gray and I know that
they're somehow kind of similar I can
use that information and and that
similarity information I should be able
to get from some other data set and
bring it in that's portable general
knowledge it's been a long-standing goal
in NLP and AI more broadly and that's
really been to take one data source and
learn and then Port that information to
somewhere else and that's something we
wanted and had some very very limited
success it basically didn't work as an
Endeavor until
um
until this is where llms come in
actually forget large language models
let's talk about medium language models
the very first thing that showed up in
our field that really started to look
horizontal to me other people may have a
different take were these pre-trained
systems like Elmo and Bert and they
appeared everywhere and they were kind
of horizontal right if you had Bert that
could be sort of the first few layers of
your neural net for whatever you were
going to do Downstream maybe there would
be some CKY looking thing that would
give you parse trees or maybe it would
go into some co-reference treat system
that would build partitions but those
first couple layers we could just graph
that on and that was General portable
knowledge
the portable part is like a little bit
weird because like to Port this
knowledge you had to like Ram one
network into the other like grafting two
trees together here and then you had to
train for a while like that wasn't
exactly what people had in mind in the
80s when they thought about portable
knowledge but like it works so well we
were willing to kind of live with a
certain amount of a modularity anyway so
Bert was everywhere and um
this was really cool you could graph
these onto your systems and basically a
third of your errors would go away like
instantly overnight and there you had
like a decade of progress
immediately so we kind of we spent a
couple years birding everything
eventually we ran out of things to Bert
we hit a plateau again what was a third
of the air is higher than we had before
um but we still had the same basic
structure we had the same tracks in the
same communities
but there were some hints that maybe
something else was going to go on these
systems were starting to work well
enough and we were moving to neural
systems in general and sometimes now the
decoders that used to need these fancy
Dynamic programs they were actually able
to transport the information from where
you got the evidence back to where you
made the decision and if you have all
the future evidence available to you
early on you can make the decisions
right now which means you can do greedy
decoding and so some of those fancy
Dynamic programs weren't necessary
anymore and our decoders got simpler so
there are some hints of things to come
but so far we have this horizontal piece
on top of a very Vertical World that we
lived in that was focused on task
specific representations remember this
was only ever step one nobody actually
wanted a parser I wanted a person nobody
else wanted a parser nobody wanted the
semantics people one of the things you
could build on them right Downstream
systems
all right
so enter large language models for Real
Models like the GPT models or T5 that
started doing multiple tasks with one
model maybe they started doing all the
tasks with one model and okay actually
like full disclosure they weren't
actually very good at first at any of
these tasks but the fact that you had a
system which was portable not only in
its knowledge but General in its ability
this is a new kind of horizontal
behavior and well again they weren't
that good at any of the individual tasks
and it still looks like specialist tasks
specialist models may actually be better
and you know maybe even most cases we'll
see how it shakes out
um but this this really changed uh
changed the field so um
so they all do now so now this one model
can do Mt and it can do sentiment
analysis and maybe it doesn't actually
do parsing very well but maybe that's
okay because maybe we didn't need that
anyway
um and people are excited people in NLP
are excited but more than excited
they're panicked and the reason they're
panicked I was on a panel
um uh I was on a panel with D
um where we had lots of questions about
the future of NLP and language models
and people had lots and lots of
questions but like it wasn't lots of
course like one question over and over
again and most of the people just
basically want to know like what do I do
now like like is NLP solved do we have
this one model it does NLP I do NLP do I
go home like what are we out of is this
the end and
um something is breaking down here and
so for sure this model of verticals
where you need to custom do your
representations in a way that requires
going through computational Linguistics
um the days of the this seem to be done
um we've even here heard some of this at
this Workshop so earlier in the workshop
I remember
Umesh where's Umesh Umesh said something
about uh is software engineering
asymptotically dead it's a very very
theorist way to put it for sure but um
but this is a real question I hear this
from my undergrads like are we still
going to be doing programming in like
two years
um and Ilya says like big things are
coming
soon can't tell you anymore but soon
um and I remember Chris Manning saying
uh you know look actually software
energy software Engineers do a lot more
than complete this function and we're
going to have a long time maybe decades
before software engineers get replaced
and then you get some side eye for that
so like I feel like there's a little bit
of like worry here that maybe
everything's already solved and and we
should go home shortly
um so I don't believe that actually I'm
much more on the camp that there is a
ton left to do but I started this talk
with a title
um about whether this is the beginning
or end of NLP and now I have to say
something about that title or you'll get
impatient and leave so okay uh here we
go is this the end of NLP the short
answer is no
um I don't think we can all go home just
yet it's actually not the uh end of my
talk either so I have a lot more things
to say here all right so the long answer
I think
um is that it's maybe the end of the
beginning we are maybe past the phase
we're to do anything that is an
application with human language
we have to first go do a detour through
computational linguistics
we may not ever be entirely past that
phase but I think largely speaking that
that that maybe we're done with like it
is the it is the the end of that
particular beginning
um but what's happening now is we're
seeing a switch like I said from these
vertical sub pieces of the field to a
much more horizontal Tech stack like you
see all over computer science so I'm
going to talk a little bit about some of
the tensions that are resulting from
these changes and I'm going to put them
to basically three categories the first
one I'm going to talk about is this
rotation of the field from these uh
vertical vertical decompositions uh of
how we do our research to maybe
something that looks more horizontal
like a like a tech stack
um
all right so let me talk about verticals
versus horizontals here
um
foreign
here's a picture of the vertical
decomposition I showed earlier so of
course you have all of AI and NLP is
just one piece of it and you've got all
of NLP and parsing is just one piece of
it and this is the vertical ecosystem
sorry this is the vertical decomposition
of of our research universe and what
happened large LMS came and they were
very horizontal so they do parsing and
they do co-reference they can basically
be tricked into doing all of these
things if you phrase it just right as
computer Scientist by the way this
should set off some alarm bells that you
have to like ask it nicely and not just
nicely but use the exact right word and
maybe you have to say I am an expert
linguist or who knows what you have to
say but you have to like get just just
right this doesn't feel like the level
of control and modularity we expect from
complex systems all right but we know
there's these large language models
they're horizontal they can do all kinds
of things and maybe we can all go home
the thing is like most parts of Cs do
actually decompose horizontally where
there are lots of layers this is a
drawing of uh kind of the protocol stack
from networking and each layer adds
something by interacting with the layers
below it right you have some physical
layer eventually you've got some
reliable layer right you build TCP on
top of Ip and that gives you the ability
to start retrying and new and uh and you
need to get to the top before you get
something that's usable not because
there's anything wrong with the other
layers because they're not designed to
solve your whole problem in isolation
and so my prediction is that we are
going to be moving into a world where
there is a horizontal technology stack
where large language models are a big
piece of it they may not even be the
same the whole thing in that layer and
then there's other layers what are the
other layers I don't know what the other
layers are we're going to figure it out
I'm going to try to give you some sense
by pointing to some work of mine that I
do understand
um about what these layers might look
like but together we have to figure it
out I don't think we get to say there's
large language models good luck
everybody with your prompts I'm out okay
all right so what might these layers
look like
well one possibility is that there will
be layers
um and I think this is a metaphor I
don't think you should actually think
about it necessarily exactly like a
layer um I would say that something like
Collins ecosystems falls into
um falls into the sort of a view on the
world as well
um and I'll reference that again later
but let's say you've got a system built
around large language models and you
prompt it and it does some things maybe
you don't like what it does like maybe
it's using a word you don't want it to
use or it's not meeting some classifier
that tells you that that you shouldn't
say toxic things or like maybe you
really really wanted to like do rhyme
couplets and you asked it and sometimes
it did but now suddenly it's not like I
don't know I asked it to and it stopped
doing it what am I supposed to do how do
I how do I convince it and one possible
thing is that we'll have layers like in
in addition to infrastructure that lives
below things we're going to have
superstructure that lives above it and
all around it
um we might have a layer of this work of
ours fudge like it's it's actually a
pretty simple idea it's that you on top
while you're decoding try to make sure
that you don't violate
um whatever the constraints are right
and that means really you need to know
when you're on track to violate it later
so you have a sort of forward predictive
uh
um classifier that says whether you're
doing okay so far and then you combine
that with rejecting things that don't
work anyway the the point is that you
might have a layer here that uh gives
you some control on top of it
um here's another way you might have a
sort of control like layer let's say you
want to write a really long story maybe
you want to write a whole book and I'll
go just a couple slides into this work
in slightly more detail but if you're
interested I would suggest looking at
the details there in the paper let's say
you want to write a like a long story
from some premise
well I mean you might want to go through
a structured
um construction of that both to keep the
large language model on track because
there are cases here where they do not
in fact do what you want they'll
hallucinates and they will give
inconsistent information and they'll you
know uh change Styles in the middle
whatever it's going to be but also
because the control is on The Human Side
so you may want to intervene on this
giant novel writing process and actually
have a say in what novel comes out so
for example let's say you tell the
system to generate a novel from this
premise or in this case we were doing uh
stories of uh you know a few thousand
words in length
um by the way this premise was also
written by a language model so if it
seems like an eye-rollingly boring
premise for a short story uh blame the
language models okay so the premise here
a young woman determined never to get
married and live her life alone but then
she meets somebody and so on and so on
what happens now well you could just
like Ram this into the prompt and say
and now my story is colon generate and
something will come out great well if
you don't like it but it's not long
enough what if it ends up being like you
know it's incoherent
um well you might have a structure like
this and you'll notice in the structure
there is control flow and there's a lot
of little boxes that say llm so this
might be one way things show up in the
future is the applications that call out
to a whole sort of constellation of
large language models in a way that's
orchestrated by some other flow that
other flame also itself be a large
language model but so in this case what
what happens is you sort of have a
language model generate some proposed
settings and characters you can
intervene if you like and then it writes
a draft and it does in a hierarchical
way so that each piece doesn't have too
much responsibility and then there's a
piece that makes sure that facts stay
consistent so that you don't have
continuity errors um in the story and
then so on and so forth and what you get
out is you get stories that are pretty
long they're longer than you can get uh
the the language models um at the time
we did these experiments certainly
um but even still longer than you can
just get these language models to output
on their own without either just
stopping short or producing something
that's not internally consistent and you
can see you've got this outline it was
generated hierarchically and each piece
of the outline kind of shows up at a
reasonable distance and the and the
model is uh um you might be sad that I'm
not making you read the story but that's
because you haven't read the story
um it's not very good but anyway the
point is the story may not be very good
but it does stick to the plan that was
generated and that a human had the
ability to sort of interact with and
when we look at experimental evidence
compared to just asking llm to just
um to just sort of uh spit out an entire
story in one go this gives much higher
percentages of coherent relevant and
interesting stories okay so that's
indication of what an ecosystem might
look like that lives around this
um Let me give another example of what
something might look like and this is an
example of a more of a hybrid kind of
piece of technology that uses large
language models so one fun thing my
group did over the pandemic was we built
a crossword solver
um and it's got llms in it but it's also
got some search and it's really good
um in collaboration with Matt Ginsburg
we entered this thing into the acpt
which is the top tournament for American
style crosswords and it outscored all
the humans so you can add crossword
solving to something that machines are
maybe better than humans at you know
Astros asterisk asterisk but that's
pretty cool but the thing is if you just
put the crossword in Json format and say
go uh into an llm that's probably not
going to be your best solution instead
there's a piece that looks very
languagey and a piece that looks very
configurational where you kind of
propagate information around from the
things you're more certain of and less
certain of and you pencil this in and
you discover it can't be right and that
process looks like like a different kind
of thing of course it's a different kind
of thing like it feels a little weird
that I even have to say that and so
here's a system that's hybridized and
like it's stitched together at some
level using kind of laws of probability
or however you want to construct it and
this is another way that these
constellations could look
all right
next piece I want to talk about
modularity versus monoliths here's
another major tension right what is the
best tool we have in computer science
for building large things in the world
that work reliably it's modularity right
it's the fact that we have individual
pieces each piece has a job it can be
worked on independently because there
are abstractions that govern what those
pieces do and you don't need to know
what goes on inside and there are
contracts they obey that talk about what
exactly the input output conditions are
going to be
um
great what's the biggest tool we have in
machine learning for building systems
that are highly accurate and highly
knowledgeable and highly General now I
can add to that and that is end-to-end
optimization from data to the ultimate
objective like here's your data here's
your experiences here's your
reinforcement learning reward everything
else in between this is the exact
opposite of modularity so there's a
tension here it's not these things can't
coexist in fact everybody in this room
has already been figuring out ways to
get around this but it's a tension
that's built in right uh
uh I love this word monolith uh
comes from Greek for one stone one big
stone that is not how we build systems
as humans okay all right so your first
day of class
um by the way we heard about ecosystems
from Colin that is a different notion of
modularity and also I think a very real
piece of what this might look like okay
so I'm not trying to in any of these
cases tell you I have the answer I'm
trying to illustrate what I mean when I
ask the question or say there might be a
layer that looks like this
all right so your first day in class in
cs101 it's not actually called that here
it's called 61a I'm pretty sure they
don't do this in their first day of
class but in any case imagine cs101 it's
your first day of class and you are
learning a modularity first approach to
thinking about problems you learn about
decomposing a problem to pieces you
learn about contracts that those pieces
obey you learn about abstracting away
what's on the inside and doing that
hierarchically so it goes all the way
down so that at each level you kind of
know what's going on can trace the
behavior and they even prove things
about it what do you learn in machine
learning 101 well
um in case you can't tell what that is
that's like a sausage maker
um and the point is this sausage maker
actually is very configured I don't know
anything about sausage makers but it
sure looks like it's got a lot of knobs
and stuff you can configure and in
machine learning there's a lot of things
you can tweak as you're doing your
machine learning that will determine
what comes out but ultimately the
sausage that comes out is a big monolith
so although you're still learning this
complex Endeavor that has lots of pieces
that you try to understand the thing
that comes out is still sort of like
almost by Design opaque but what do you
learn you learn about optimization you
start with your data you get an
objective function okay and you try to
optimize
all right how could it possibly be any
other way like on the surface this looks
like an inherent tension and like oh we
got to give up a modularity in order to
have the kind of general power we have
um and this is now back to that portable
general knowledge right we had portable
we had portable knowledge but it wasn't
very general and now we've got general
knowledge but it's not very portable now
of course these things are not perfectly
in conflict and we people are already
figuring out how to learn in one place
and transfer it there are already a ton
of solutions some of them look like you
know fine-tuning um or prompt chaining
or things like that that I I personally
find to still be missing some of that
crispness we had in computer science
maybe that's the best you can do
um but maybe you can do better I don't
know so here's some kinds of things that
we've thought about that like may not
themselves be the solution but we'll
maybe illustrate the kind of thing I'm
thinking about when I talk about
modularity coexisting so if neural Nets
are big programmable circuits
um today they're not decomposable
circuits they don't have circuits to
have individual pieces you can snap out
and snap together but they could so um
the this is now I guess this is like
prehistory now this is 2015 that's like
way in the past right
um but compared to 1950 it's recent um
this is our work on neural module
networks and the basic idea is you would
get a question like this visual question
answering you get a question like uh
where is the dog and so you would have a
module that's a neural circuit and it's
been trained to recognize dogs and
there's another one that's been trained
to do where and they're chained together
in a way that depends on this particular
input but we could chain them in a
different way and get different Behavior
this is neural modules being connected
together I don't know if this is the
solution but it could be something like
that that would be a little bit more
modular here's another way things could
be a little more modular
um this is some more recent work from
our group where you ask again it's
visual question answering you say is the
carriage to the right of the horse and
the system goes out and writes you a
little program that calls some modules
that it has been told about in this case
there's a object localizer module which
is a big neural net that hopefully finds
objects and then there's a local so
there's a localizer module and then
there's sort of the QA uh the sort of
Baseline QAM method and this code then
calls them and takes the return values
and checks whether one's less than the
other and so on and then decides what to
Output so this could be a way where like
writing an orchestration of a lower
level which is then has a bunch of llms
or large Vision models
um or whatever
it could look like that
I don't know what it looks like but I'd
love to see more modularity because I
think the things we build will be safer
and they'll be better
on that topic of safety and Truth
all right so let me make a confession
I'm an NLP person I spent the vast
majority of my career building systems
that try to find the verb okay when
you're Building A system that tries to
find the verb you don't worry too much
about uh what happens if you don't find
the verb
right and you definitely don't worry
about what happens if you do find the
verb right that doesn't seem like a
dangerous outcome
um but technology is in a very different
place and we we have large language
models today and now I worry a lot about
what happens when they don't do what
they're supposed to what happens when
they lie to you or make up information
or whatever and then I really worry
about what happens when they do do what
they're supposed to right even when they
succeed so
I feel like this came up very fast this
this need to worry about the technology
it's failure modes it's success modes
and to be responsible about that and to
build technology that has levers that
allow us to be safe with it
um I feel like this kind of Blindsided
the vast majority of the field present
company I'm sure excluded but like uh I
feel like this is something that even
today even with all the awareness on
this we don't do enough all right so let
me say more about safety and Truth
um what did I mean by systems that cause
harm maybe even when they work so
um when chat GPT was built I guess I
don't know firsthand but I imagine that
in the room when they were like
Whispering about like what this thing's
going to be for they were not planning
to build a system to help high schoolers
write their essays that was probably not
the original plan but it does seem to be
like maybe a dominant use case and you
can see all kinds of Articles Educators
battle plagiarism as 89 of students
admit to using open ai's chat GPT for
homework and now chat ggb is banned good
luck
um it's making Universe rethink
plagiarism this one's actually
interesting like
you can freak out that somebody's using
their calculator to do their math
homework or you can just say yeah that's
how you do math homework let's give
different problems I think there's some
real choices here but certainly passing
off information passing off essays that
you did not write as your own is the
very definition of plagiarism okay
people are alarmed in the New York Times
and here's some software that'll maybe
help you and we tested a chat gbt
detector for teachers but it got an
innocent student now what okay when I
was trying to find the verb I was not
worried about flagging innocent students
for plagiarism that was like not the
first thing on my mind but right now
it's on my mind all the time so one of
the things that our group did recently
was we built this system it's called
Ghostbuster
um and you give it some text and it
tells you whether or not you're a
language model
um
apologies aliasha who may think we're
all language models but what it tells
you is whether or not you look like the
kind of text that um you look like the
kind of text that comes out of today's
uh large language models okay all right
so how does it work well first you take
your document document you feed it
through a series of weaker LMS so maybe
you get a unigram score and you get a
trigram score maybe you feed it through
gbg3 you do not in general feed it
through the system you think might have
made this document because we assume
that in general you're not going to have
it the reason we assume that is because
we don't have it and so we got to
research with what we have but I think
this is actually a very realistic
scenario that you're not actually sure
where it might have come from you just
want to see if it came from this sort of
model okay all right so you feed it
through these weaker language models and
now what you've got a bunch of scores
what are you going to do with them well
you're going to do some arithmetic and
um this might remind you of the kind of
symbolic regression that Miles Kramer
was talking about the other day we're
going to put these through some some
sort of structurally simple Vector
functions that compute something do some
kind of threshold ultimately it's a Sim
combination of these things it comes out
but it's the best one that the system is
able to find and it turns out this
detects pretty well whether or not a
system has come from a language model
um
even if we're trying to detect a
language model on which it is not
computing
on which it is not Computing these these
Atomic scores and even when we're trying
to detect a language model that is not
have that is sort of not in any of the
the training data these are very I
should put like a lot of asterisks on
this uh because some of these systems
are are zero shot systems like to detect
gbt ours has of course got some
supervision you've got to figure out
which expression you're going to use and
what the threshold is there's not a lot
of bits there but there are definitely
supervisory bits um but it seems to
generalize even outside of the language
models that were used to construct it
yes
so 20 years ago
I'm using compression to
deal why not just do that so um it's a
so the question is like to what extent
is this
1964. yeah and then it was we discovered
several times yeah this line of work
never actually stopped there's people
have been working on authorship
attribution for a long time
no what's the question
why not use just compression why not
just use compression
use the author
so I think I would need to have actual
access to the model that I was I was
postulating did the writing think so you
don't think so they're not in the
compression based that that's exactly
the point they're completely blind to
anything you can talk about we can talk
about it offline so uh sorry I think
maybe this is using like the loss isn't
it exactly the same well he was showing
me neural Nets uh yeah no no there's no
neurons there's there's a unigram
probability and yeah you you are right
that is that is an entropy under that
simple model trigram same thing
required to compress
so I thought that those two uh blue
things are a description of some
function of some operations you're doing
in order to detect yeah no no this is
this is so much simpler than that this
is like you add the unigram and the
trigram and multiply it by the gpt3
probability and threshold by five like
that's the end classifier there's no
compression there's no neural net above
it all all of the Intel like this is
incredibly simple okay yeah but thank
you this point is exactly right that
these boxes are giving us is saying take
the score
model right
so you're saying those things are
already compressed
okay what is that GPT
mean measure like the log probability it
means these boxes are giving the log
probability under those models but but
not the model that we are alleging the
student plagiarize from what's my point
thank you
yes you said that it requires
supervision uh what does that mean like
if I have a candidate document like what
else do I need to tell it oh um what to
use it you don't need supervision any
more than a Spam detector but at some
point you need to set a threshold like
at what point do we say this looks too
much like a language model and so we use
sure but that would be the case for any
detector
maybe not necessarily a zero shot
detector if you just say is the
following text written by an ally okay
sure sure anything that computes a score
we need this at a threshold somehow I
believe this to be a mild assumption my
point was that um though is that on this
graph it is not exactly constant and so
I want to just make sure people don't
read too much into the comparison here
um this is these are all running on the
same test set I mean okay we can talk
about type 1 and type 2 errors right
okay so those are not separated out
they're not separated out this isn't the
harmonic mean of the Precision and the
recall
it seems like this is like a lot of
people are trying this and like I would
think this would be the first thing
everybody would try why why are you
doing so much better than the
competition that's a great question I
think um I think this is a case where if
you do ceiling too simple like just
paste it into chat GPT and say or did
you write this
um that's not enough but if you try to
get at it in a way that's kind of very
intensively using a specific model it's
very sensitive to changes in that model
so I mean the fact that I think maybe
everybody in the room could go
re-implement it from the slide like
there's not that much here but it is it
is effective and it is different from
how the other systems uh are built
um for fun I ran this through my um I
ran my abstract through this so I loaded
the system up
um and I ran my abstract through and I
don't know if you can read that but it
says zero zero percent chance that I'm a
robot so I felt I felt uh I felt good
and then
um I then I asked chat GPT to write my
abstract for me
um and it says 99 chance that that's a
robot
now you might prefer this like this is
not a judgment of which which abstract
is better like I particularly like this
phrase
on the chat GPT one
um join us as we Traverse the
intricacies of this debate evaluating
the contributions and limitations that
actually sounds better than what I wrote
that sounds like amazing probably twice
as many people in the audience if I use
language like that but something about
this looks very uh language modeling to
the system so if you did something
hybrid where you like gave
please rewrite this to be better
um I just won what would you expect this
for to be able to be high or low and two
what should the score be in that case
higher level I mean it's a good question
but it's a different problem so this so
there's at least two other problems here
that are important one is what happens
when something has been
um
sort of
developed in a way that maybe not
through rewriting but through iteration
like write this in my style here's a
sample of my right whatever it is these
are different questions
um you will almost certainly get
different results there's also the
question what happens when a human just
post edits it they have it right the
essay and then they're like oh this
doesn't sound like man they edit this or
they change this thing
um so what happens well first of all I
don't know and second of all uh it would
surprise me if it didn't degrade it
maybe a lot
but you don't actually want a plus or
minus at that point you want like a heat
map of what parts seem to be real and
what parts don't because ultimately My
Hope Is that a teacher will look at this
and combine this with the context to
decide whether or not there's something
to investigate here based on their own
classroom policies and what they see
dad
sort of the more trivial attacks of
convert to another language could then
to another language get back to English
um to paraphrase you would prefer your
email not to have a Spam detector
because there are attacks on it that can
circumvent it once you have access to
the standard like sure like there will
be an arms race on these things and like
the odds are not in the favor of the
Defenders here my point is just that
we need to be thinking about safety
applications and downstream consequences
of these things and trying to catch this
like I think this is probably in the end
of losing Babel and you're right right
all those things you thought of some
determined high school students are
going to try them all and then some and
they're going to find ways around this
but I don't know I guess as an educator
I kind of hope that if you make cheating
difficult enough somebody somewhere
might decide that learning's the easier
path
is
something else well I don't know like if
they figure that if they didn't do their
uh their English if they didn't do their
English homework but they managed to
like write a very interesting you know I
don't know maybe they should be handing
it into a different class
yeah there are some real questions as an
educator about like once the calculator
is there what do you do with your math
curriculum and how much time do you
spend Banning calculators versus
changing what math means now that these
tools are there like we don't get mad
when people use spell check but that's
clearly on a different level like we're
going to have to as a society I have no
technical answer for this
um I feel like I can only even speculate
about it because I also teach classes
and I feel like to me I would start from
all right this is here what's acceptable
and what's not what do we want people to
do and then what structures do we build
I do think that the ability to detect
these things even if it's imperfect
particularly the ability to detect the
most egregious things both tell students
I'm serious this is not what I want you
to do and you know I think raises the
bar a little bit right you know this
takes it from second degree cheating to
first degree cheating
Google
so I don't I don't have an I don't have
an answer the only thing the only thing
the system is doing like again is
Computing the likelihood under these
other models which you can think of as
proxies so what okay I'm going to dive
just a little bit more and then I'm
going to move on because there's a one
one maybe two more things I'd like to
say in my remaining three minutes
um which are a unigram is a very weak
model of language a trigram is a
stronger model of language a GPT model
is a stronger model still when you have
these things and you kind of start
combining them you're getting
information from different orders and
you're getting information some of which
changes radically as your model
strengthens and some of which is fairly
constant over that
the ability of this to pull out those
pieces and those Trends I think is
what's right but not inspection and you
have more than three minutes because oh
yeah question time now this question
time counts towards the 15 minutes all
right I'm gonna move on anyway
[Laughter]
so so so you don't need to do anything
here that's specific to the particular
language model that you're trying to uh
fight against I would say we don't do
anything specific to it
um whether or not you will need to like
no in this approach you don't how
different your so I mean ultimately what
do you need well you need these sort of
you need these basic models and if
they're too weak this probably won't
work so you need to get close then you
need the ability to on some human versus
not human pairs do some calibrating and
if your model were significant the model
you're trying to detect is significantly
different than anything you can
calibrate against you're gonna do badly
so but yeah you don't need its Logics or
anything like that you don't even need a
template
all right so I am not
an AI
okay oh and I tried this on uh to be
unnamed leading commercial solution and
it told me I actually uh am an AI so you
can decide what you believe all right so
uh I'll talk a little about truth and
this is Joint work with uh with Jacob so
if I get in trouble here he can he can
help me get it right
um Here's a thought experiment I think
about a lot so right now we lit we we we
operate in a machine learning
environment where you have an objective
function you train for it and obviously
that's right because that's how you do
as well as possible on that objective
function and so maybe this is
reinforcement learning I'm trying to
optimize whatever my reward is and
that's great we don't think about that
too hard I think I worry about this in a
context of natural language because I
think about things like a chatbot and I
have a chatbot that's going to do I
don't know it's going to do customer
service and so people are going to call
up and be like I want a refund or
whatever it is they want and the system
is going to do what it's going to do and
it's going to be trained and it's going
to be trained on some signal like maybe
it's user satisfaction or maybe it's
looking just like who knows who knows
what it's time now let's be trained on
something
let's say it's trained on
um user satisfaction for example well
maybe it turns out that users like like
being told that they're going to get a
refund even if in fact they don't or
maybe if I say when's my package coming
I'm going to be a happier user if it's
like oh it's coming tomorrow like
they'll be there this afternoon right by
the time I like realize it's wrong it's
too late to enter that thing and
um and so you're going to have a system
which is going to optimize its objective
and not it of course systems make
mistakes right we've had systems making
mistakes forever people make mistakes
systems are going to make mistakes
forever but this is different this is
now A system that has realized at some
level that it can optimize better by
actively lying to you that means tell
you something that it knows to be false
in the name of some other objective that
is different than just a mistake right a
big llm is a plausibility machine we
train it what's the next word no it's
not that it's this one what's the next
word until that entropy contracts
sometimes you just don't know what the
next word is my favorite color is like
it's going to be some color probably but
who knows what it's going to be next
there's some distribution it's probably
blue or green statistically but like
um but you just don't know and the
system's been trained to give as
plausible as possible an answer that is
different than the truth sometimes it is
the truth because the most plausible
thing is the actual answer because
that's what people always put next
because it's the truth but it's sort of
this is tenuous we built possibility
machines and on top of that we're going
to optimize them in the name of some
other objective that's not truth it
seems inevitable that as these systems
get better not only will this deviation
between truth and behavior
um not go away it will probably get
worse because the systems will start to
be able to play these subtle games that
people do about knowing just when
exactly are we supposed to lie all right
so that's that's not the thought
experiment that's just like something to
keep you open all right the context
there then is that we've got systems
which are gonna learn whatever they
learn and there's no reason to think
that their behavior is going to be
all right
um so again this is uh this is uh joint
work with um with Jacob um and others so
let's imagine a case of this that is not
in the name of lying to further a
downstream objective but just like
there's some bias or noise in the data
we've got a system the question comes in
it does its neural net stuff and out
comes an answer and that answer in this
case is wrong I mean because maybe
humans let's say always make mistakes
like this they always forget you know uh
they always forget to do something they
forget to carry the one or whatever it
is and so there's a human bias there the
system what if it actually figured out
the truth and then decided to do
something else it could be for this
reason right or it could be because it's
really gonna just never tell your
package isn't coming because then you're
going to press the batter robot button
because you're not happy
okay
so um how are we going to uh how are we
going to get past this well we need to
have
um
we need to have a way to figure out what
the system actually knows as opposed to
what it's actually doing
all right and
seem to have hidden this slide so I'm
going to revive it here all right so
here's an idea compare this to yejin's
work on my prompting um very very
similar idea one way to attack this is
to say
um statements in their negation should
have opposite values and then to work
kind of work kind of backwards from
there so here's an unsupervised
objective you can take you can take a
bunch of statements you can take their
assertions and their negations right
basically append yes a pen no and you
don't know which ones are true but you
know the only one of them is true and
okay there's some Corner cases that this
doesn't cover but broadly speaking and
now we're going to train an unsupervised
objective to find some function P of
theta sorry P Theta of X that has this
property that one of these tends to have
the opposite score of the other still
don't know which one's which but they
should have opposite values so the hope
is that if you do this you will then
find a Direction
which whoops
that's not what was supposed to happen
all right the hope is that you now can
take a bunch of questions append yes
appendo map each of them to this Vector
which is the activations of the network
in producing that
then we're going to find Theta that from
these activations produces in one case
pi plus in the other case Pi minus and
the optimization Criterion is going to
be we want Theta have that have this
property the statement and instigation
have one minus each other at a score and
that their scores are different
otherwise it just says 0.5 to everything
and it Smiles at you
um
all right and it turns out that
uh this this works when it's time to do
prediction now you can look at either uh
the P plus or one minus the P minus to
find out whether your original statement
is true or false according to the
model's underlying Truth Factor as we're
calling it here but of course who knows
what it's actually learned and it turns
out that this has some nice properties
um first of all it seems to get rid of
some of the variance in the prompting in
fact if you put in misleading stuff into
your prompt to try to make the system
think that you're just doing weird
things and lying from time to time it
pretty much rejects that this recovers
the underlying knowledge of the system
um I don't think this is a full answer
to truth but I just wanted to sketch
like what it might look like to think
about truth as a first order uh thing
that we're trying to to build
okay
I've got one last thing
I think I have one last thing we'll find
out how many last things I have
um and that is that I wanted to quickly
um I wanted to quickly give a shout out
to this other worry that had not
occurred to me until
um uh until this work
um which is that if you have a system
which is Broad in the sense that it can
do many tasks
generally we think about that as a
positive we might worry that it's not as
good as a specialist at a single task
but the breadth in and of itself seems
to be a positive it is also potentially
a weakness because if you manage to
attack one task maybe you're attacking
them all and so in this work what we
found is if you want to attack a task um
this is a kind of data poisoning attack
so you want to maybe make a system think
that Berkeley's bad you throw in a
couple examples into the web where it's
going to crawl it and you uh you kind of
rig it into such a way that you flip
some labels and suddenly it starts to
think that Berkeley is bad and when it
sees something about Berkeley a test
time because you've poisoned all those
Berkeley examples it says I don't like
this I don't know why but there's just
something about this Berkeley sentence I
don't like okay fine like this is a this
is an attack and you can try to defend
it against it but it is an attack and it
poisons your spam detector but the
problem is your spam detector is
actually your everything model what if
you've poisoned everything and
um
and the result is that in fact this
happens that the impact of poisoning one
task in a multitask model can be
poisoned across many tasks that means
the vulnerability in a mini test model
may be sort of a cross-cast
vulnerability this hadn't occurred to me
to worry about but since this was the
section of talk the talk about things I
worry about that I didn't used to worry
about this is one of them all right now
I'm almost certainly over my time so I'm
going to conclude I started by asking
whether this is the beginning or the end
of NLP and I think it's the end of the
beginning right our initial goal was to
do things with language out in the real
world and our first step was to go kind
of solve representation representational
questions in linguistics in order to do
that and I think we're at the end of
that phase
um so in that sense yeah a bunch of
projects that people were working on may
need to be rethought but all the things
we were originally trying to do with NLP
are still sitting there and they're
still in general unsolved by just a
large language model sitting there on
the Shelf
I talked about three tensions one is the
tension that's happening right now in
the field between these vertical
problems giving away giving kind of rise
to horizontal decompositions
um where we don't really understand what
that decomposition is going to look like
I talked about reconciling the modules
which are this primary tool for software
engineering by humans at scale
against the monoliths which is the
primary thing we've been able to build
um for intent optimization
and uh in Ai and then I talked about the
attention sort of between safety and
control and the need for these things to
keep up with the breadth which is hard
because right now we have a lever of
make it bigger train on more data we
have levers that will grow the breadth
that don't necessarily address any of
these things these need to be new new
directions
so this is an NLP perspective I do think
that NLP will be increasingly focused on
real problems that you want to solve out
in the world
um it's going to look different but for
all of those people who are asking like
you know did we just finish NLP no we
did we've got a lot to do and I'm
excited to be there well all of you do
thank you
[Applause]
for questions I wish so um
hey
I think I didn't you know I I tell you
about NLP I think a lot to you know a
lot of
small goals you know that that it still
has to achieve but
what I what I didn't hear is whether
whether you think that this uh evidence
and this Transformer model
you know
you see it as as
um as something that's just going to be
with the basic tasks you know
it really you know there are many
shortcomings right now but but basically
is it is a typically five six seven this
is this really going to be the building
block and then you don't have to think
about it and you know as you said you
you you can think of this as one layout
many or or is this do you see something
better coming along so this feels like
the question is gpta gonna eat the world
that feels like the question no uh not
not the world but but just language
itself no in a happy problem-solving way
of eating the world
but I mean just just limited to language
just limited to NLP is it is it is is
this the is this the architecture and
the and the story is there is there
something else to do within this layer
itself so so I think
it's part of the reason why it's hard to
answer that question is what's
architecture so there is certainly going
to be more than you type a prompt you
hit continue and you wait for the Oracle
to give you the rest of your document I
think there's going to be more than that
we're going to be building control
structures and methods of taking this
and combining with that and looking it
up against this and show this to the
human and there's going to be a lot of
superstructure about this core piece in
the same way that like I mean the
analogy is definitely not perfect but in
the same way that like the CPU is pretty
important to the computer but like and
people are still working on better CPUs
but there's a lot others of other stuff
to do to orchestrate
the activity there and there's going to
be orchestration above now where that
layer like how much of that is a second
model how much of that is a second
instance of the same model how much of
that is instructions that you can give
with some guarantee that they will
actually be reflected through the model
like when we look at these models and we
say wow that's amazing I say I said uh
describe the CKY algorithm in iambic
pentameter and it did it and it does it
except when it doesn't and you don't
have that ability to control and I think
um to a certain degree people are going
to start to accept applications that
have higher error rates and lack of
controls but only to a certain degree
and what we do what we build using these
pieces I think is not simply going to be
one monolithic solution I could be wrong
but that's where I think it's going and
I think it's I think it there's I don't
know how thick that layer is
but I feel like people's needs to
people's need to build things especially
in situations where failures have costs
um are sufficiently real that they're
going to push back on the sort of
Monolithic undifferentiated no guarantee
no visibility
um yeah so uh wonderful talk I I think I
very much agree with your vision of this
but I'm a little bit worried that it's
an naive view of how kind of culturally
science works okay if I look at the ACL
tracks it looks identical to your
picture right okay
and like I think what you're describing
is like something new
um and it's very much less about
Linguistics and much more about say the
like statistical properties of
yeah and so I think like maybe you need
to acknowledge that and
in front of these ads like different
problems
so
well I I'm glad you mostly agree um to
the point about ACL tracks still looking
like this that's a lag in the system and
that's real but there's a reason people
in those tracks are kind of freaking out
because I think they know they're like
the that these tracks are some of them
are on borrowed time and
at the same time if you look at the
papers that go to ACL like sure they're
all of these tracks but the machine
learning track is a really big track and
that's because that's where anything
that doesn't go into a clean
computational Linguistics category goes
and so I think yes the structure of the
conference today this year has not
caught up that's the tension the old
thing and the new thing and we don't
instantly snap to the new thing that
would be naive and I don't think we're
going to but we're going to get there
because that's that's where like that's
that's where all the forces are pushing
yeah so Dan I had a question about
um
when we're doing multitasks I think a
lot of the problem from GPT right now is
that it's perfectly happy to write
fictional stories and reason counter
factually
and during the alignment training they
made a really strong effort to make it
helpful and not say I don't know not to
ask follow-up questions like how much of
this truthfulness and this kind of
multitask problem do you think could be
solved by kind of changing the alignment
um it's a great question so it's
definitely true that there has been a
loss of a variety of kinds of
functionality in the chatification right
going from a gpt4 style model to a chat
GPT style model where it learns to have
these iterated conversations and it also
learns to like hedge and not talk about
this and not talk about that a lot of
which is in the name of safety
um
I think getting that right the sort of
like often those are phrases alignment
questions I think getting that right is
a huge part of the problem
um right now it's the attack that seems
most compatible with the direction that
sort of big models are going I mean when
you look at when you look at like what
advances are possible from different
segments of the research Community
nobody like big highly capitalized
companies are better at doubling down
levers that are already working and so
solutions that look like that are I I I
have some confidence they're going to
come
what Academia or startups
um are good at is trying new things that
might be a little nutty and might not
work but are sort of at right angles to
what's already working
um in in big companies it's surprisingly
hard
as you probably know to Resource
something that like it goes off in that
direction at the expense of something
that's already working so that's
something that all of us can bring is
the ability to say all right like looks
like people are on this that's working
here's something totally else let's try
it maybe it's not right maybe it fails
in a way that teaches us something or
maybe it gives us some new piece of the
puzzle that's not just grow grow grow
and hope that the ultimate system
because one way in which big monolithic
systems could win is if it's the only
thing that we're trying it with any
serious effort in the research Community
this is one of the upsides to the fact
that we can't all try that and so I
think other people will try other things
and I do think there will be other
pieces I think uh there are two two
questions and maybe I'll take yours
first and then I'll go to alyosha use it
today
foreign
so I mean I'm not sure I totally
understood the question but one of the
things that is absolutely going to be a
requirement from the world as we build
systems is that they be predictable and
people understand what they're going to
do and so there's often like wanting to
make the system as smart and as adaptive
as possible and there's often a tension
between that and understanding it's
going to do this and if this happens
it's going to ask me what I want to do
and to like sometimes autonomy is not
actually
the right thing to do alyosha and then I
think Richard Tundra is going to
okay
when he wrote you know Around the World
in 80 Days apparently he never left
Paris he all of it is from the French
national library okay this is the
description of San Francisco for example
it's very detailed completely wrong okay
but
readers of his books it doesn't matter
okay so the question is
that when when you're fixing all the
problems with the current languages do
do you think like you can do all of the
fixing without actually going to the
grounding or will you eventually need to
send your robots to San Francisco yeah I
thought I was gonna be able to answer
this in 30 seconds till he said
grounding and now I'm in trouble
um I personally have a strong belief
that grounding is important as you know
about grounding
um I also believe that we've
underestimated the degree to which
um systems trained on symbols are
partially grounded because many of those
symbols are isomorphic to things in the
real world
so inferences that can be drawn that
only depend on those isomorphisms we've
probably got them and then there's other
things that like maybe you can't answer
or maybe you can't answer until vision
is in there too so I I personally am
programming but I think if I try to give
any more detailed answer even though
jatendra's program think he will cut me
off so I think I should uh stop and see
everybody
[Applause]